is mr. Morosi on the phone excellent JP
Morosi of MLB Network and also Fox
Sports kind enough to call into the show
how are you bud that's all you and your
family are doing great we are hopefully
you are as well John hopefully you are
as well let's get into it where do
things currently stand as you and I are
talking in the world of Major League
Baseball and the idea of playing in 2020
well this is a big week there's no
question about that rich that we saw
yesterday reports the owners have
approved a plan to return to play and
now the negotiating begins with the
Players Union and and by all appearances
is not going to be a quick one it's
going to be one that takes some time and
I think MLB realizes that there is about
probably a month or so between now and
when the rescheduled spring training
would have to begin and so that does
give them some runway to to negotiate
the particulars of this with the Union
but there already appears to be a
certainly a very strong difference of
opinion between MLB in the union as it
relates to compensation and the separate
question becomes the public health
equation and the safety of players and
their families the testing bandwidth
it's going to be required to get
baseball operational during the course
of this time so there are a lot of
variables competitions a big one but
there are many many factors at play
during what's going to be a very busy
week so let's walk through it you know
we had Charlie Blackmon on our show
yesterday and he said hey you know I'll
quarantine what's the sense is this is
this plan in involving quarantine what
are the details of this plan and in
terms of the logistics of a season well
it's a great question rich we don't know
all the details as we speak right now
other than to say that the plan
certainly includes multiple variations
within it and by that I mean that there
is at the outset the rather optimistic
view of being able to play in major
league stadiums in the respective major
league cities but there also has to be
the allocation for what transpires if
there is a flare-up in in case
as many public health experts believe is
likely at some point in time that if
that occurs what then happens does the
league shut down does the schedule get
suspended or does that team then move to
a different city and/or a tighter
quarantine where they are those
questions are still out there that there
they have not been resolved in candidly
even the health experts of our country
don't know exactly what course this
virus is going to take and what that
means for what the safety guidelines
will be in various and diverse states
and cities across the country so the
plan has variations within it as it
should and I think the Charlie
Blackmun's point there are players who
are comfortable quarantine but there are
others who may have wives who are due to
give birth this year who are not
comfortable with that so I do believe at
the end of the day rich that a majority
of players if presented with information
that says it's safe to play will want to
play but this agreement has to include
some allocation for those who's again
family circumstances make playing a lot
riskier and a lot less comfortable for
them and I think it's incumbent on both
and they'll be in the Union to find a
way to take care of those players well
I've also heard from people in
management who you know you know and
they and they love their they love the
players but think that some players will
not be quarantine able that that guy you
know the if you will boys will be boys
and somebody will do something that you
can't police at all essentially as the
concern forget about the the adults who
have wives and children you know but
that's it's just not it's not feasible
to quarantine everybody John right and I
think to some extent rich it's going to
be dependent upon first of all whatever
the restrictions are in that particular
area as we know we've got 50 states and
that there are a lot of different
strategies being implemented right now
depending on where you are in the in the
u.s. that will determine what is legal
to do but to your point
not everyone has been following the
guidelines or even the law so
that is a variance that has to be
allocated for and the testing likely
would occur according to what experts
say probably not on a daily basis but
most certainly on on a weekly basis and
and even the weekly test obviously would
would require some bandwidth on the
national stockpile of tests and the
commissioner Rob Manfred has said
publicly from the outset rich that he is
not going to be comfortable bringing
back the sport until he has been assured
that the testing regimen required for
baseball is not going to compromise the
bandwidth that will take care of the
public health for the rest of the
country so as much as baseball would
love to be part of the healing process
and being a be a place to come together
as a nation to watch our national
pastime every day as badly as baseball
wants that outcome
baseball also realizes the the social
responsibility that precedes all of that
John Merrow see MLB Network insider here
on the Rich Eisen show another thing
that Charlie Blackmon said to us as he
said that when baseball in the Union
gets together he hopes that the politics
don't get in the way I asked him what he
meant by that
he talks money he said money was the
first thing out of his mouth and then
you just said that there appears to be
already even without a lot of details of
this plan having leaked out or being
known you said at the top of our
conversation about a divide between the
Union and the folks who are running the
sport already
so these issues connected John well I
think the divide first and foremost
economically speaking is is there has
been reported widely that there's a
difference of opinion Tony Clark has
made some comments already the head of
the Union about his view of the interim
agreement that was struck in March now
the particulars of that are open to
interpretation and not surprisingly they
are being viewed differently by each
side the players say they already agreed
to a salary reduction MLB says that and
this is a I'm paraphrasing here and and
quoting the reports here that MLB looks
at it and says there was a clause in
there that basically says this Agreement
will go into effect only if and when
there are no travel restrictions and
fans are back in the ballpark that's
when this agreement of return to play
the framework would be valid obviously
that's not the case right now we still
have restrictions of travel in our
country and most importantly there will
be no fans at least at the outset of
perhaps not at all yes and and that's
40% rich of MLB's revenue so there has
to potentially be and I think logically
one would say further acknowledgments
and changes to the payroll structure and
the cost structure of the of the game
because you're missing 40% of your
revenue
so John ballpark it for me if you don't
mind the phrase what happens now the
conversation between the Union in the
and and the Commissioner in his office
and his officers go down today I imagine
it's happening as we speak what what
happens
I believe rich first of all that we
should prepare for a lot of negotiating
back and forth probably some some
comments on both sides about frustration
because that is a matter of bargaining
that is basically every labor
negotiation that you and I have followed
in the course of our careers as
broadcasters involves some element of
that and so I would expect that and not
be surprised by that I do believe that
at the end of the day that both sides
will realize the incredible importance
in finding a way forward this year and
that there will be an agreement to
return to play economically now that's
separate from the public health
conversation but the economics of this I
believe will be agreed upon there is
simply too much at stake to let
economics be the reason you don't return
to play the public health questions are
frankly so much more important in a
broader sense that they could very
easily on their own prevent baseball
from coming back but both sides realized
they cannot let economics be the reason
I believe there will be an agreement and
then it's going to be a question of a
month from now
is it safe to begin spring training and
around the fourth of July is it safe to
begin playing regular-season games
that's still about six weeks away and
you think back rich six weeks ago our
country was in a very different spot
so when you think about how much our
country has changed in a very short
amount of time it's important to realize
that the situation could evolve further
in the next six weeks and hopefully
hopefully I stress it's in a positive
way your wife's a doctor right John she
is rich at your alma mater at the
University of Michigan so it's been both
a trying time at home but also one where
the the contribution of our family has
been without doubt with what she does
for a living and certainly all
supporting her so what does she think
that's a great question I don't ever
want to put words in her mouth certainly
on this matter as much as all others and
probably more so than all others and I
know I don't want to have her have her
the public statement in any way and to
speak for it but I will say this I am
looking at this from a standpoint of a
sports broadcaster and and filtering the
information through my prism and I will
often say things about hey I I hope that
I'm traveling again sometime this year
to cover baseball games hey I hope we
have baseball again and she will often
look at me as she does rich when I say
other things on other topics with that
kind of weary eye and a smile and a
raised eyebrow about John you have to be
patient day by day and so I guess if my
if my experience being the spouse of a
doctor is is of any value to me as a
journalist or to me as a citizen I would
just say for all of us it's great for us
to think and plan positively and
optimistically about our sports because
they're they mean so much to us and so
much to our society but we also just
have to keep listening as I know I do to
the doctor in my life and her her
perspective because at the very outset
rich I remember this distinctly she said
basically we all have to give the
doctors a chance to help them save as
many lives as possible and that
certainly also involves staying home as
much as we can still now because we are
not in any way out of the woods on this
thing yet and it's up to us to make sure
that even if the first wave has passed
in certain areas of our country that if
we're reckless the second wave comes
quickly so I think we all just have to
do our best as citizens to help the
doctor save lives and and just keep this
going day by day and listen to the
science that
we get every every single day well John
I mean look it makes sense I think maybe
the only thing you're gonna do is glove
up mask up maybe drive down to what is
it called Comerica still I'm sorry for
the I mean that that's it I mean like
that I mean it's going to be different
it's going to be a different look for
all of us and I go back to Mark
Wedemeyer a friend of mine who works now
for the Kia Tigers and in Korea and he
says listen John we get our temperature
checked every day the support staffs all
wearing masks we've got no fans in the
stands but when the game is being played
it's still baseball and we're really
privileged and lucky to be there and so
I think if we keep as a sports country
and in sports society if we maintain
that level of appreciation and humility
that we have to do everything right in
our lives broadly speaking in terms of
social distancing and when we're at the
grocery store wearing our masks and
doing everything we're supposed to do we
have to do all those things right that
will connect us to the things that we
love and if we do our part as citizens
then we've got a chance to have the
Tigers and the Dodgers and everybody
playing on TV for us to watch every
night but all of us are invested in that
success and I'm optimistic that we'll
get there but it involves continuing a
great citizenship by us all John thanks
to the time thanks for the call best
your wife and stay safe to your entire
family thanks rich likewise keep doing
the great job you do on the show it's
probably my cue that's shot John Merrow
see JP Morosi of Fox Sports and MLB
Network
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here